you're watching reason live streaming to
you from Los Angeles the following is a
live conversation between the host the
guests and the online audience if you'd
like to participate please leave your
question in the YouTube chat the views
expressed by guests and the audience
members in this discussion do not
necessarily reflect those of reason and
now your host Zach why some more hello
thank you for joining us on day two of 5
of this livestream experiment and we are
gonna be talking with Leonor scan Daisy
today she is the original free-range
parent one-time dubs America's worst mom
and you're gonna see why in just a
second but we are gonna be talking with
Leonor in just a few minutes but first
for those of you who are back for this
second day thank you for participating
and remember this is a participatory
forum so ask questions in the chat and
we'll be sure to get them to Leonor this
is a bit of an experiment we're just
trying it out for this first week we'll
see how it goes we'll see what kind of
feedback we get and we'll see what kind
of viewership we get and if it's worth
continuing we'll do it on a less regular
basis in the new year maybe more
something like once a week and it
doesn't always have to be me in this
host seat we can have a rotating host
and just to give you a little preview of
what's coming the rest of this week I'm
thinking of this as a little bit of a
sample platter so a little bit something
different yesterday we had Josiah Zehner
talking about biohacking using cheap
technology to change your own genome and
the implications of that for us and the
world today we're talking about Leonor
scan Daisy about how to maximize your
own child's freedom and that this is
gonna be great for parents but even if
you're not a parent it it should be
relevant to you because children become
adults and
we are now dealing with the consequences
of children who were raised by
helicopter parents so we're gonna talk a
little bit about that we're gonna talk a
little bit about the philosophy of
free-range parenting and about Lenore's
new project let grow
she's partnered with the social
psychologist Jonathan height on that
it's some pretty exciting stuff so we'll
get to that and then tomorrow we're
gonna be talking with Rick Doblin who
founded Maps the multidisciplinary
Association of psychedelic science and
there is some really exciting stuff
happening in the area of psychedelic
research and we are on the brink of
seeing these things legalized for
medical use and then we'll see where it
goes from there so I'm excited to talk
with Rick and that one's going to be at
1 P 1 p.m. Pacific 4 p.m. Eastern
tomorrow and then Friday I want to
mention this we're gonna be bringing
reasons own niklas beyond and we're
gonna touch on a subject we already
touched which was post-modernism and I'm
bringing that up only because I want to
start soliciting questions for that now
we've already gotten some some
interesting feedback to that that we'll
be responding to but if you have any
questions for Nick on that topic
questions at recent comm is where you
would send us and now we're going to get
into the conversation with Leonor but I
want to start by playing a clip from a
recent TV documentary produced by Jim
Epstein with Leonor that I think will
give you a sense of what free-range
parenting is where Lenore's coming from
and then we'll come back and get right
into the conversation with Leonor so sit
tight several years ago when my son was
9 he asked if he could ride the subway
by himself and my husband and I let him
I wrote a column about it and two days
later I was on The Today Show MSNBC Fox
News NPR I had obviously struck a nerve
what did you think about your mom
letting you have this opportunity I was
like
finally nobody could believe that a
decent mother would let her son go
underground by himself and let him find
his own way helped me it was letting him
have a little independence that he was
ready for thousands of blog posts later
I wrote the book free range kids I have
a television show now called world's
worst mom that's me so I started a
business call me if you're really
nervous and I will send your kids
outside while I lock you in doors it's
as simple as that
and I've done it several times and it
just works it works because reality
breaks through this gigantic fear that's
been foisted down parents throats that
they have to be worried about their kids
every single second so it all started
with that subway ride Lenore and your
son was nine year old nine years old at
that time so I might back of the
envelope math that he is 820 off on a
vacation okay
so he he turned out okay no he never got
kidnapped or on the tracks yeah okay he
actually got stopped a couple times when
he was on the Long Island Rail Road as a
ten-year-old for riding the rails as if
he was a hobo and what was interesting
is that the first time he was stopped
it was Christmas morning and they
stopped the whole trains that would have
been literally ten years ago and the
conductor refused to call me but he
called the police and when is he got off
at his stop he wouldn't let the train
continue on until the police had come
and called me and I had said yes this
this is what he's supposed to be doing
and she was visiting some friends those
friends came and escorted him to their
house so that was fine and then the same
thing happened a couple weeks later and
I thought it was him pranking me because
but no is they actually the same
policeman they're just sort of obsessed
by danger and I said to the policeman I
said look it's it's rush hour there now
and you're stopping the train again
aren't you don't you think that he's
safe there's so many people there
getting off the train it's just
a normal day I was in Bayside Queens and
he said I said you know you could you
could handle even if there was a
kidnapper you're there you can handle he
said what if there's two kidnappers so
that's when I started realizing oh this
is going to be a challenge because
rationality is not going to play a role
in this discussion
you can always imagine the very worst
case scenario and at some point
somewhere in history something terrible
has happened and you can always bring it
up and say what about that and that's
really what I've been dealing with for
the last 11 years what about that Lenore
what about that time that something bad
happened and when you you wrote about
this letting your son write home for the
New York Sun in 2008 and you that kind
of launched an entire movement and when
you when you first did that and like
when you first
let your son step foot under that subway
did I I mean obviously you didn't know
all this would happen but did you think
that this was some sort of momentous
event or did did you feel weird I mean
obviously you felt it like it was out of
the norm enough enough to write about it
but what were you thinking as a parent
when you first did that you know I
didn't think it was out of the norm
enough when we did it when our son had
been asking me and my husband you might
see drifting by from time to time if we
would let him take the subway by himself
yeah take him someplace he'd never been
before and let him find his own way home
and my husband and I discussed it and we
thought yeah he's ready for this this is
how we get around in New York City
there's so many people on there we think
there's strength in numbers safety in
numbers and he speaks the language he
could read a map so we decided to let
him and when he did it was a it was a
lovely day for our family our son was
very proud he was excited to feel out to
do it and to come home he felt so
grown-up but I did not write it about it
for like another month and a half
because it didn't strike me as momentous
or newsworthy even though I was brining
out column after column and I was
writing about it and then one
when I had no problem to to speak of I
said should I write about is he taking
the subway because by that time I'd been
talking to some of the other
fourth-grade moms and saying oh you know
what is he took the subway home and
they're like um and that was what gave
me the impetus to write about it not
that I thought when I was originally
doing it that it was something for it
wasn't an experiment it wasn't for
publicity it was just part of growing up
and since then it's just been this not
only an incredible ride hood to start
the whole free range kids thing but to
be exposed to what is normal now for
children in terms of freedom and
independence and it keeps shocking me
there was a piece on PBS last night on
the NewsHour and I hadn't seen who
they'd interviewed but they'd
interviewed some kids who were being
allowed to do a let grow project which
we can talk about later but it's being
allowed to do something on their own and
the the boy they featured for the most
part was a fifth grader and he had been
on his block he'd been allowed to be
like go down the block and come back but
he had never been allowed off his block
and so for his exciting electro project
he went two blocks and it was the first
time two blocks away there's actually a
park so for the ten years of his
childhood so far he'd never been allowed
to go to his local playground by himself
and this was this was him like somebody
opening the cage door and finally
letting him out and and that is not
abnormal these days it really the the
limit on children's freedom is is
shocking to anybody I'd say over 35
there there's a question that just came
up in the chat that I want to ask it's a
Phillip Kevin EC asks I always wondered
did is he suffer socially due to all the
attention over the years now he didn't
suffer so did he become the most popular
kid in the school he's got friends it's
the only thing that affected him at all
is that he was on TV a lot
I ended up going to a high school where
they teach television production and he
likes lighting so that was it that was
that's the sum total of the yeah okay so
you mentioned that the reason that you
started thinking this was perceived as
abnormal is your mom friends or other
parent friends at school started you
know giving you the raised eyebrows and
now it's as someone who has two young
children it's there's there I have a
fourteen month year old 14 month old and
a three almost three year old and the
three-year-old just fell into duck pond
this morning so I don't know if that
qualifies as free-range parenting or not
but the were you there I hope I was
there I pulled him out he learned from
the experience I think but you know
don't don't lean over into a duck pond
with a stick but there's now and now
there's social media and there's all
these parent groups and blogs and the
reaction to me see that that seems to be
the sort of barometer that a lot of
people are using to calibrate that's a
little bit of a mixed metaphor I guess
but the have have you been had have you
gotten many responses or gotten a sense
of how social media is affecting parents
these days for good or bad in terms of
free range parenting the thing that's on
social media that interests me the most
is not the back-and-forth thing and in
fact actually we have we have a Facebook
page called no more helicopter parenting
the let grow support group it has all
those names just for search engine
maximization but that's a place where
people are talking to each other and
it's it is very supportive I can
understand where parents you know like
to ask questions and get the the feel of
the group and I'm not on the other one
so I'm not watching a lot of whether
there's you know shaming or whatever but
the the thing that I do collect the way
other people collect baseball cards is
Facebook posts written
my mom's who it always goes like this I
never thought it would happen to me I
was at Target or IKEA or the grocery
last night with my two darling children
and I was in the the frozen food aisle
and down at the end was some creepy guy
I'm not seeing it well we went three
aisles over and there he was again and
then when I was checking out I noticed
there was another man outside with a van
and the door was open I'd have no doubt
that they were there to sex traffic my
children and thank God I didn't glance
down at my phone or I would never have
seen them again mm-hm and and they write
this and of course the upshot is that
literally nothing did happen really if
you if you go through this you see that
a mother was shopping with her children
and there was some other shoppers there
and and there was actually a car in the
parking lot and she left and she went
home but it's written it's always
written in almost those exact words like
I didn't think you could happen and they
always say but and then they say Abilene
Texas you know Kansas City wherever they
are they say is the number two sex
trafficking place in the country
everybody's number two because that
sounds believable and then there is a
cascade of comments underneath wow that
was so close whew thank God mama you
really did a great job and and to hold
your children tight and never look away
and and that I really I find extremely
disheartening because people share those
by the thousands and there's something
that is rewarded on social media which
is the excitement of a near-miss talking
about sex trafficking kidnapping and
being the hero of the story and then if
you share it you're you're you're sort
of part of the story and you're helping
to keep children safe but actually all
you're doing is adding to a hysteria in
the country that is not matched by any
any bit any iota of reality because when
I talked to the head of the crimes
against children Research Center all
they do is research crimes against
and I asked him how many children have
been abducted like this in public from
their parent by a sex trafficker and he
said zero Wow so in terms of something
that I do see so you mean sex
trafficking sex traffickers are not
abducting toddlers and then raising them
until they're liable oh my god again
with door I'm so sick of Dora the
explora now they're not doing it and yet
people feel that it's real obviously
they must feel it's really to be really
cynical to be spreading these rumors and
then I've actually written about it a
couple of times our reason sometimes the
news media pick up these stories and
they act as if they're real mother
writes up near miss at you know rest
stop at IKEA in the you know in the
chickpea aisle so it's um you know the
news media loves that story too and
nobody seems to care whether it's based
in reality or not so long as they can
get eyeballs there's another good
questions this came in from Christina
Dellinger and this'll be a good entry
point to just give an overview of the
free-range philosophy I think she asks I
have a one-year-old and I'm very
interested in raising him free-range
what would you say are the first steps
with a toddler so to get into that
question maybe just explain what
free-range parenting is and then what is
the right age to start yes yeah okay so
free range kids which I now call let
grow because my new nonprofit is called
let grow is is basically old-fashioned
child rearing it's knowing that kids
love you can look back to your own
childhood and think about what you love
to do and chances are your parents
weren't with you every single second of
the day maybe you got to walk to school
play with friends outside explore in the
woods build a fort walk the dog and this
is just trying to renormalize what was
completely boringly normal a generation
or two ago so nobody let their
one-year-old free-range a
ever in the history of the world so
you're not going to let the the
one-year-old go toddling out the door if
they're even toddling yet but one of the
things that we do believe is that we
seem to nowadays replace everything or
think that nothing happens naturally
that you need a class on tumbling that
you need somebody with you to to walk
you to school that you can't possibly
organize your own game of kickball it
should be in a league with a trophy and
you can't get anything out of just
noodling around you have to enroll in a
class and so you have a little kid at
home your little kids at home too one of
the things that kids really love is free
time free time with some junk around you
don't have to spend it on expensive
things I loved the lawsuit against the
Baby Einstein videos a few years back
from the campaign for a commercial free
childhood they sued because the Einstein
said these are educational videos if
they said no not really worse to watch a
video than to just play with but there
was a video Baby Einstein unlike about
water and it's like you could you could
fill a bucket with water and have them
play with it they don't have to watch
video so so you don't need expensive
toys you don't need classes your kid
would benefit from some time with some
other kids around
they don't need everything to be a
teachable moment they actually learn
from moments they teach themselves so
you don't have to say now you're playing
with mommies don't play with battery but
battery battery starts with Bubbe you
know honey this is the battery you don't
have to worry about them knowing their
letters and their numbers and being
school ready
I'd say before seven but I know that's a
little radical maybe before I were six
you know you just there's so much the
kids are learning from being in the
world from you know playing with stuff
from exploring the idea that the only
way they're learning is if you can tell
that they're learning something that you
that is academic is untrue they're
really playing is the work of childhood
that's that's not me that's that it it's
Piaget and there's one more question
from the chat and then I have another
clip I want
bring in and to bring us to a slightly
different topic the question is from
Beebe question if the overwhelming
evidence that child kidnapping is not a
real problem as you say what and that
won't convince people what will like in
other words how do you actually win this
argument persuade people right first of
all it's not an argument everybody gets
to raise their kids the way they see fit
I just if if you want to give your kids
some freedom
you should be allowed to by law you
should be allowed to and the social norm
shouldn't be such that somebody is
berating you or calling 911 simply
because you're walking then letting the
kid walk the dog or play outside and
they don't agree with it here's what
I've discovered in eleven years of
talking about the same topic
nothing convinces people I can't
convince people let's put it that way
statistics don't matter my fantastic
statistic which is that if you wanted
your kid to be kidnapped by a stranger
do you know how long you'd have to keep
them outside unattended for this to be
statistically likely to happen do you
know no Zack I guess how long would you
have to keep the kid outside without you
there for them to be kidnapped a
statistically likely beginning which is
sort of like how many lottery tickets do
you have to buy before you'd be
statistically likely to win the lottery
I'll say 12 hours well that would be
scary no it's 750,000 years so people
get it wrong let's just put it that way
but anyway so the statistics don't
matter if I tell them if I tell people
which is true that anxiety rates of
children are going through the roof
depression I hate to say it's suicide
rates are up and one of the theories is
that you know you have an internal locus
of control when you feel that you are in
control of your life but if you have
somebody who is micromanaging you even
at work you know how tense you are you
know how miserable it is to go into work
and you start feeling depressed and
downtrodden well imagine if somebody
woke you up every day and dragged you to
school and then you're they
and then you leave school and then
somebody drives you somewhere and then
you're at a Kumaon and then you're out
of coolin and somebody drives you and
soon you're at ballet and then somebody
takes you home and then it's time for
homework and then it's time for
read-aloud and then it's time for
putting the stickers in the book and
then you go to bed I mean there's not a
lot of internal locus of control it is
external somebody else is determining
pretty much how you spend every single
second of every day and to a certain
extent they're they're grading you and
judging you certainly the school and the
after-school programs so anyways I can
say all that and everybody nods along
but that's not what convinces people
here's what convinces people when the
school does the let grow project because
it's really hard to get people to let go
of their kids unless there's an external
push and that is the school saying that
your kids homework tonight or sometime
over this week is to do something by
themselves they can go run an errand
they can write their bike they can walk
to school they can go next door they can
make dinner something by themselves
without you when the parent is pushed to
do something that they weren't ready to
do yet because nobody has any idea when
to let their kids do anything on their
own anymore everything is written in
terms of it's too dangerous too scary
too hard but the school says let him do
it and the kid does it and the kid comes
home and they brought they brought us
lerp e they got a loaf of bread they had
the greatest time they come home and
there there's a hole in their pants
because they were sliding into first
with a you know having the time of their
life
that changes the parents that's the only
thing that changes the parents appear
yeah yeah the excitement of seeing that
their kid is blossoming it's it's I mean
I'll tell you a story after story a
parent who I just I would have never
thought they could do it and they do it
and afterwards they're like where's my
kid oh I don't know I sent him out
before oh it's now yeah I wonder where
he yes they relax and because because
something fundamental has happened and
it's not just that they're proud of
their kids or they're startled that the
kid wasn't taken it's been 12 hours why
isn't you kidnapped yet it's what
they're happy about is that they've done
their
job I mean they don't they don't say it
that way but I think people's ecstasy at
seeing their child independent was so
out of whack to me with the mild thing
they would have done like that child
yesterday who walked two blocks instead
of one block at age ten I can guarantee
you that mom is on cloud nine and it's
because we are programmed we are you
know we're born to to raise these kids
so that they live when we aren't alive
and there's no proof that that will be
you that you've been successful until
you see that your kid can do something
on your own on their own and when they
do that's what changes the parents so
you're you're the questioner whoever you
are hi out there once you let your kid
go and if you're the person with the one
year old it's going to be a while but
once you let your kid go and do
something on their own right me cuz
you'll feel it hmm there's a we have an
example of that here it's another clip
from that same documentary we showed at
the top where you coach some parents
through letting their two children let's
take a quick look at that and then
analyze it a little bit great I worry
that if somebody saw him by himself and
he was vulnerable that I don't know what
could happen they've been walking for a
year they're in New York City yeah
turtle legs what and you're not that far
from a grocery and it's still light out
I don't think it's raining uh could we
ask them if they're gay would you be gay
there we can ask Li and the kids and see
if it's something that
they want to do and something you're
game for I'll be nervous but if if
they're comfortable with it do you feel
comfortable crossing the street yes
using the street light yes okay that's
one of the reasons I think we're
particularly worried about cars today is
because we're with our kids all the time
and when you're with your kids you look
out for the cars so it looks like your
kids aren't paying any attention
whatsoever if you want your kids to be
really safe you can't do everything for
them you're not building a competent
child had you not specifically asked
about it and had they not brought it up
I don't think we would have probably
thought them do this anytime in the next
probably year I think I see you felt a
little bit out of control and you know
just hope that that they were okay
[Music]
so you said you had a follow up there to
that particular story what what happened
first of all they were fantastic I loved
that family
secondly the dad mostly when I you know
I did a whole television series that was
similar to this where I would meet with
extremely anxious parents and basically
hang on to the hem well I said their
kids have to do something and usually it
was the mom who was more nervous and
this was a case where the dad was and
weirdly the dad had grown up in Santa Fe
with his twin brother riding bareback on
horses through gullies you know the
horse with no name and loving his
completely free-range childhood and yet
something this is why I don't blame
helicopter parents something had rose in
him with beer I mean I was just
listening and watched this clip for a
while and I heard the two words that
were so interesting one was if my child
would be vulnerable I mean we really are
with sort of program now to think of our
children as vulnerable to everything
vulnerable to you know to bullies to to
scary people to up to depression to
anxiety we really frame children through
their vulnerability as opposed to
thinking of them as pretty sturdy anti
fragile competent and he said another
word he said what they're comfortable
with that and you know trying to bring
up kids who are always comfortable is I
think part of the problem because we've
been told that you know if children are
uncomfortable it might be a little
traumatized or it might be painful and
that's not what we should be giving them
we should be giving them comfort and in
fact Peter Gray who is one of the
cofounders of let grow said that what
children need is children come with
their brains ready to be wired right and
in if they're in China they learn
Chinese and if they're here they'll
learn you know at some English and and
what they need is play they need all
this back and forth and frustration and
betrayals and losing and winning and
getting lost and trying to figure things
out and when we make sure that they're
comfortable all the time you know that
is sort of the trophy culture I lost it
but I
used to have my son's eighth place
trophy out of nine teams from a teenage
bowling team that he was on anyways if
your goal is to make your kids always
comfortable and we're sort of told that
we should it's not like parents come up
with this idea themselves this is the
culture that they are swimming in then
we don't get used to them being
uncomfortable and they don't get used to
feeling uncomfortable and and suddenly
discomfort becomes a real threat like
you're making me uncomfortable which
means like you must stop because that's
a threat to me and no being
uncomfortable is just part of life and
actually those kids did not seem very
uncomfortable walking to the grocery I
think they were ecstatic but but here's
what I learned afterwards so so they
went when they got the they got
cranberry juice and they came back so I
can't remember if I was filming a
follow-up for you guys or for somebody
else but we needed a family that had
gone free-range or let grow and so I was
there maybe six months or a year later
and by this point you know the kids were
walking back and forth to school it was
no big deal the Sun was staying
afterwards he'd go to the park and play
baseball with his friends I mean it
really it is so easy to change parents
that's why the electro project is so
great because you know it doesn't take a
lot it takes seeing the kid free you
know competent to change the parents but
anyways the guy said the dad said that
he had been back home to Santa Fe and he
had been speaking with his nephew who is
a pastor and he told him about this
whole experience and how it changed him
and how he didn't understand even how it
had happened and the pastor said you
know you always had a deep faith in God
but now you have faith in your kids and
that's that's what I'm talking about
faith in your kids will change you faith
in Lenore Wow
what do you do you're in New York City
I'm in Los Angeles this family was in
New York City these big cities seem
different to people than living on the
bucolic countryside so how do you
navigate that if you want
like how do you walk that line between
safety and what can be an unsafe
environment and trying to give kids in
these urban settings as much freedom as
possible well I I think if New York City
is pretty safe although I am nervous
about cars you know what I say is that
there's there's never been a time that's
been perfectly safe and so it's always
been parent's job to prepare their kid
you know you can't prepare the path for
the child so you prepare the child for
the path and that has always involved
you know teaching them and prepare like
getting the money like some parents I
haven't taught their kids to look both
ways before crossing the street that
that is our job you have to teach kids
that they can talk to strangers but they
cannot go off with strangers that way
they have the whole world to talk to and
to ask for help from and to learn from
but they can't go up with anyone they
can never get in anyone's car if
anyone's bothering you kick scream yell
you know teach them some landmarks you
you go and you find if there's a decent
route to school you walk that with them
and if there's not then you have to you
know you go through safe routes to
schools or you come up with an
alternative but your job is to gradually
you know work yourself out of a job make
sure that your kids are understanding
your rules set boundaries just like you
would do at home you know yes you can do
this no you can't do that well you can
go this far but you can't go over there
you're gonna go to some friends house
after school you got to call me you got
to let me know in advance so it's it's
the same thing that your parents did for
you and it's just we have this almost
amnesia one of the things I talk about
with Tracy Tomaso she's the executive
director of let grow is how when our
moms send us to school and my mom had me
walking to school at age five and that
was normal back then um that was normal
back then that's the whole thing there
was a community that all knew the
milestones at five or six you could
start walking to school at nine or ten
you were old enough to have a paper
route twelve thirteen you were old
enough to babysit but these milestones
that everybody sort of saw they were
clear a generation or two ago have been
buried under layers of fear until the
point where you can't see them anymore
and can you walk to school at five or 15
when when Jonathan Haight who's who
wrote the coddling of the American mind
and he's another one of electro founders
does lectures and I watched him do this
three times recently great lectures he
looks around the room the audience and
he says okay
anybody who's over I think he does 35 or
40 I want as I look across the room I
just want you to call out what age you
were when you started having some free
time and he looks around the room and
everybody goes everybody was over 40 you
know 7 6 8 6 5 all those ages and he
goes ok and then hopefully it's a mixed
age group and he'll ask ok anybody I
don't remember what yeah I think it's
good for an after 85 what age did you
get some freedom and he looks around the
room and you hear 12 15 13 12 13 and
that's a gigantic social change in a
generation or two and the reason is not
that these are horrible helicopter
parents who are crazy nut jobs because
you don't have an entire culture filled
with outliers they are in liars and it's
because they've all been told that
everything is too dangerous that their
kids are what we're saying
Mulder bull that you have to make them
comfortable and they've been taught this
they've been taught this by the media
that always takes the worst-case
scenario and presents it as if it's an
instructive thing for them to see so
remember parents because this child was
you know something horrible happened in
Australia hold your children tighter and
then parents magazine my favorite
whipping boy and if I had a copy here I
would show you Jonathan I wrote about
one of the parents magazine articles
that drove me crazy Asst was about how
to have a playdate like like it's so
hard first of all the idea that there's
instructions for these drives me crazy a
and then the instructions B so one of
the questions that they posed it as like
an
i scowl and one of the questions was
your child is old enough no much my
child is old enough to have to stay home
alone for a little bit but now she has a
play date over can I run to the dry
cleaner and Parents magazine replied
absolutely not
ah you want to be there what if there's
a horrible accident they always go to
horrible accident a and B was and what
if there's a spat you want to be there
to make sure no one's feelings get to
hurt so a normal parent went looking for
advice from the Bible of the parenting
world is told that her child cannot
handle an argument with a friend and
that she as the mother must be there
observing this whole thing and like a
referee and ready to jump in because of
the horrible trauma that could erupt if
the child's feeling was one of the kids
feelings got to hurt and then you go
back to Peter gray saying you know
playing is partly about your feelings
getting hurt and then I wanted to be
Superman I want to be Superman okay I'll
be Superman now and you it's it's all
about negotiation and and you know
coming to terms with you know dealing
with other people and not always getting
your way and sometimes the ball is out
and you wish it was in and and and
instead we've been told to take all
these experiences out of our kids lives
to make them happier and safer and
psychologically Hall and it's one of
those ironies it's like being told to
eat trans fats no it's like oops sorry
we do and Jonathan height is one of the
cofounders of let grow and that's an
organ organization that we'll talk about
in a little bit because I want everyone
to get a sense of what you're trying to
accomplish with that but he as you
mentioned wrote the book co-wrote with
fires Greg Lukey on if the coddling of
the American mind based on this article
this Atlantic article or an expanded
version of this Atlantic article and he
is looking really at the the results of
this generation that you mentioned post
1985 I'm right on the border I'm 1984 so
I think I might've been
early escape that although I have some
tendencies all admit but the so I want
yeah I want to talk a little bit about
how that manifests because what we've
seen we everyone knows about these
eruptions we've seen on college campuses
and I did a short video about the
concept of microaggressions and bringing
in this referee and so I want to play
that clip from that video and then let's
talk about what happens when children
who are the results of helicopter
parenting because helicopter parenting
helicopter culture helicopter culture ok
so because it's it's schools it's the
advice they're getting the American
Academy of Pediatrics is always telling
people to beware so it's it's really
it's coming from all sides right and as
you mentioned you know pull you know
police officers are now enforcing a
certain style of parenting so yeah we I
want to get to some of the cultural and
legal forces in just a minute but let's
take a look at this clip and then talk
about that Occidental College in
California is considering instituting a
system for students to report so-called
microaggressions perpetrated against
them on campus microaggressions are
statements that intentionally or
unintentionally send a negative message
related to someone's membership in a
marginalized group we visited campus to
ask Occidental students if they agree
that the following statements could be
considered microaggressions
they've all been documented as such on a
college campus somewhere in the United
States have you heard of the term
microaggression yeah that's a big thing
on campus if we see large-scale violence
we can name that as a macro aggression
but the way that we devalue that
violence the way that we silenced that
violence that's a micro aggression I'm
asking an asian-american where were you
born yes
very very contextual you know that's not
a microaggression that's just asking
whether they will pull telling a black
student that he or she is very
articulate that is yeah about saying all
lives matter
um I think because the history behind
black lives matter it's kind of like
appropriating a statement that was
created specifically to talk about black
lives being lost at police brutality so
that is I'm colorblind I don't see race
[Applause]
I believe the most qualified person
should get the job qualifications aren't
really the only only things you consider
when hiring someone and if you're saying
that the most qualified person is
someone who is not a minority you're not
a religion you believe in then yes I'd
be a microaggression
saying god bless you after somebody
sneezes oh that would be a
microaggression
because of different religions yeah it
could be a microaggression to someone
who doesn't believe in God I think that
the harm there is relatively minimal so
there's still some harm though I would
say there's not harm but if it's being
asked clearly someone found maybe mini
microaggression perhaps do you see any
downside to creating a database full of
statements that faculty and students
make to each other in terms of
protecting free speech values on campus
not in terms of protecting free speech
value but the idea of a database
certainly raises eyebrows so yes we do
need a system where we can report our
experiences and that like a system of
education or whatever
so how do we get here
well remember I was telling you about
that Parents magazine article that said
that you must sit with your child when
she's having a playdate because what if
there's a spat you want to intervene if
you've been raised by a culture that
tells you that any time that you feel
uncomfortable sad or hurt it is a cause
for adult intervention and it's not
something that you can handle on your
own and that it's possibly huge as
opposed to roll with the punch I'm not
surprised that children grow up feeling
that a free Sun of anger frustration
confusion or hurt is that cause her
calling in the Dean I mean we you
remember that you know the the fairy
tale about the princess and the pea II
do you know that fairy tale do ya mm-hmm
yeah you did right I mean so there's the
the princess is the one who can feel the
pea under about 13 different mattresses
because that's how sensitive she is and
we've been told to raise them we've been
told to raise our kids that way oh my
god is there a pea under that mattress
let me take off all the mattresses and
remove that pea and you know and and
flatten it out and then we'll put these
on it how does that feel is that good
cuz I don't want you to be uncomfortable
that word and so if you've been told
that discomfort is evidence of something
being really wrong I'm not surprised
that we start saying well that sort of
made me feel uncomfortable
um but the the other thing I was
thinking is that they we're also raising
kids with sort of pretend dangers we
tell them that things are dangerous that
aren't my the thing I think about the
most because this is what I get the most
letters from from parents is parents who
let their kids wait in the car for
literally three four five minutes while
they're picking up the Tylenol or a
pizza and they are charged with neglect
and the
that they are charged first of all the
reason that somebody calls 911 and then
the reason it progresses from there is
because somebody truly believes that
this is dangerous now it's not and
there's no child I don't think I can
think of who's died in a four or five
minute car wait the children sometimes
it's tragic sometimes children are
forgotten in cars and and and that's
that's terrible but that's very
different from you know forgetting your
kid in the car when you go into work is
different from letting your kid wait in
the car on the iPad while you're picking
up the pizza so if you've grown up
surrounded by pretend danger and you're
told it is real and there are actually
real-world consequences then I'm not
surprised that you start confusing micro
and macro aggressions there's been
there's there's no difference between
something almost non-existent danger and
real danger if we're arresting parents
for letting their kids walk home from
the park walk the dog then you you
there's no grip on reality
yeah and in there as you're mentioning
you can get arrested for this stuff now
you've documented and reasoned plenty of
stories and parents getting arrested I
did a video which we're gonna show
another just short clip from of a man
who was arrested for letting his child
walk home from school and there's
there's a question here that came in
that kind of teased us up for this that
it's a good question from the veal would
full even if we want to raise free-range
our kids laws sometimes prevent us from
leaving our kids in the car or letting
them walk to school and citizens help
and force those laws they tattle on the
parent that did the bad thing so what
can we do about that so let's let me let
me just play this clip from Mike because
this is actually a little bit of a
complicated case in in my opinion it's
it's a little bit of a bubble case so it
might be interesting to discuss so
here's just a clip from this documentary
based in
Southern California Mike tang was
charged with child endangerment for
leaving his eight-year-old son in this
parking lot a mile from home it was
supposed to be a life lesson the night
where I dropped him off I just wanted to
reinforce that money is hard to earn and
he doesn't do a good job at school he
could end up you know doing something
like this or sleeping out here where the
homeless people sleep he dropped him not
far from the recycling area and walked
away
sometimes as a guy there and you see
people on bikes they look kinda ragged
could be homeless Mike says his son
Isaac had been slacking in school the
last straw was when Mike caught Isaac
cutting corners on his homework by
reading his little sister's book instead
of his own
it's an eight-year-old kid who didn't
read his book right why would you do
that well first of all I've tried other
things right and they didn't work so
that's my take on it and I'm trying
different things if this doesn't work I
might try something else next time
about 10 to 15 minutes after dropping
Isaac Mike sent Isaac's grandfather to
go pick him up
it was 8 o'clock and getting dark turns
out Isaac had already been picked up he
was in police custody a stranger had
spotted Isaac and called the cops he
said why was i walking home and did I
know where my home was did you you know
how to walk home from park yeah I know
why to walk from my school to my house
the cops arrested Mike and he spent the
night in County Jail a jury later
convicted him and the judge sentenced
him to attend parenting classes and to a
56 day work release so that's not
exactly that's not exactly the parenting
decision I would have made and I think a
lot of people would kind of raise their
eyebrow at that sort of punishments for
a child but that raises an interesting
question to me because where do you draw
the line between your personal distaste
for a parenting decision and where the
law should intervene well to me it's it
is it's pretty easy to see what is
actual abuse or neglect as opposed to a
parenting decision that I might not make
or that you might not make I mean you
know what neglect is neglect is when you
have blatant disregard for a child's
welfare this was not you know I haven't
left my kid maybe I had maybe maybe
letting my kid ride the subway was so
horrible but this was anything but
blatant disregard this was a dad doing
his best maybe not doing what you or I
would do or the viewers would do but
loving his child and trying to teach him
a lesson not beating him not starving
him not giving him drugs not not doing
anything other than saying maybe a walk
home in and a route that the kid knows
that when the kid said that he knows the
route from the school to his home he
passes by this particular parking lot on
his way
daily
so to let him walk home and think about
that does not strike me as worthy
government intervention and to the
earlier question how do people who want
to do free range parenting or or let
grow as you're calling it now how do you
do that in a world where you can get
arrested yeah so I gave lectures about
this for ten years and said so we have
two free-range our kids and then
somebody wrote to me and said how can we
change your kids you need a law that
says it's legal and I thought oh yeah
you know I didn't think about that
that's true so then I started ending my
lecture is always saying and we have two
free-range our kids we have to make it
normal again to let our kids go outside
and you know if you don't want to that's
okay but if I want to I would like it if
there were other kids out there too and
then we have to make it legal and after
hearing one of my lectures Lincoln
Fillmore who is a state senator in Utah
thought it made sense and he drew up a
law and he called it the free-range
parenting law and it said it's not
negligence to let your kids play outside
walk to school wait briefly in a car
under some circumstances or come home
with a latchkey and if anybody is
reported for those things absent any
other evidence of something actually
wrong like you know the child is chained
to the radiator then it's not abuse or
neglect and it passed both houses in
Utah unanimously and was signed into law
this past spring it was the first free
they called it the free range parenting
law now you can call it electro law I
really don't care what you call it but I
would love more states to pass a similar
law that says really what neglect is is
blatant disregard for a child's welfare
it's not you raising your kid
differently from Iowa nobody thinks that
anybody else is raising their kid right
I mean every sister-in-law and every
brother-in-law's I can't believe they do
it that way so unless we're talking
blatant disregard that shouldn't that
shouldn't be a legal issue if you don't
want to if you don't want to try to pass
a whole law in your state you can try
passing
summation in your town that's what the
town of Ithaca New York just did I think
Wilton Connecticut is thinking about
something similar where you say we want
kids out and about and rather than
thinking the worst of their parents we
will support the parents and you cannot
go up to kid are you okay are you lost
you fine okay you know your way home
good rather than calling guess what I
just saw a child out here and I think
people would rather live in those
communities I would I mean I would
rather know that my neighbors care about
my kids and are giving me the benefit of
the doubt then they can't wait to turn
me in and what's strange about some of
these 911
they are so mad at a mother or father
taking their eyes off their kid but they
can't wait till the mother goes to jail
all right right here to take their eyes
off their kids so it's there's something
strange going on but once again I feel
like that too has been primed by a
really distorted idea of when children
are safe or unsafe we really have come
to this strange new conclusion that if
your eyes are on your kid they're safe
and if you turn away I mean literally
people think if you turn away you turn
back and they'll disappear when those
people are writing these Facebook posts
about I thought my child was going to be
taken from me thank God I didn't look at
my phone
I think they truly believed that had
they looked down they would look up and
their child would be on the streets of
Thailand or something they there there's
no there's very little grip on boring
old playing pretty safe reality yeah I
mean a sign of how strange the times are
is that we're now having to pass laws
and proclamations saying okay this
activity is not illegal I mean that's a
kind of strange law if you think about
it but I mean we need this I mean you're
it seems like there has to be this
cultural shift in these at a community
level in order to normalize you you have
to have an environment where that's
normal in order and there will hopefully
be some sort of
you know add on effect there and I guess
that's what the the let grow project is
another thing first which is that if I
gave yet another name to what I'm
working on and what a lot of other
people are working on now I would call
it the benefit of the doubt movement
let's give parents the benefit of the
doubt let's give strangers the benefit
of the doubt let's give our neighbors
the benefit of the doubt most of us are
doing the best we can if we haven't
taken the kid into the store it could be
because we're working two jobs it's
exhausting the kid has you know
tuberculosis we don't want to give it to
everybody else just sort of assume that
everybody is doing their best unless you
see something egregious and that is
statistically likely to hurt the child
for minutes the car is not statistically
likely to kill anybody otherwise we'd
all be dead the Freak train came by and
we had to wait in the car for it to pass
so you really have to try to recalculate
towards sort of generosity towards your
fellow human beings and a little less
hysteria when it comes to how how
terrible the world is because we are
living in the safest times ever we're at
a 50-year crime low here in the United
States we're back to the crime rate of
1963 we really are we're almost
ungrateful that we are living at a time
that you know in America where you don't
have a war on our soil there's no famine
the water supply unless you're in
flinches is you know safe the foods but
unless you're romaine lettuce is
basically the fact that I can say two
exceptions means that most things are
decent now and we're acting as if it's
World War three out there so how do you
renormalize all of this how do you get
the kids back outside so that your
neighbors are used to seeing them there
so they don't call 911 they see one like
an escaped lemur from the zoo so the let
grow project in schools is simple fast
and free and the schools that are doing
yeah that's our website right there like
row and you click on schools that second
little tab down there and you'll you'll
be led to a little video that shows the
like
project in action which is teachers tell
the kids to go home and do one thing on
their own that's all they have to do we
give them a list but they don't have to
take something the list but the list is
there and because you decide it with
your parents it's something that they
are ready for you to do even though we
are giving a little push and like I was
saying before that's really it just
breaks the ice the this fear like I
can't let my kids do anything it's so
scary no it turns into look at my kid
but the other let grow initiative that
we have that we're doing through schools
is Peter Gray's idea and it's keeping
the schools open after school for free
play because of what we were talking
about yeah that's Peter gray is
fantastic book oh my god I love that
book it's so so great I read it big fans
well yeah I did yes
yeah after I saw you read it yeah yes
yes I did and I want to implement it but
again you run into these challenges of
being in a big city where no one has
this mindset but I'm hoping that
initiatives like let grow are going to
you know create these little these
little zones but maybe you can talk a
little bit more about that yeah so
anyways the reason that we we want
schools to stay open for free play is
that in free play you learn you know the
compromise and the creativity leadership
frustration tolerance because you and
your friends are coming up with
something to do when you're making it
happen and add a a let grow play Club
which is what we call it because we're
slavishly trying to pound our name into
people's heads let grow play club it's
it's at the school so parents trust
where the kids are the parents who
wouldn't necessarily let their kids go
to the local park let them stay at
school so it's also convenient if you're
working you don't have to get going to
get your kid there's mixed ages there
and Peter Gray said that one of the
things that our culture has lost is ages
planning together because if you're in
Little League gets the seven and eight
year olds and it's the nine and ten year
olds but if you have a 12 year old
playing and there's all different ages
and the five year old comes up to bat
the the 12 year old is going to throw it
gently I mean they're just gonna
inherently instinctive
throw it gently to the five-year-old and
that is the beginnings of empathy and
the five-year-old who if he was playing
with his parent might say I want another
turn not fair you know and be a baby
they don't want to be a baby around the
cool twelve-year-old or even the cool
seven year olds so they suck it up and
they go to the back of the line and
that's the beginnings of maturity and so
it has always been and we've taken that
opportunity out of our kids lives as
well the wrong side sorry so um so if
you have a free play club after school
you have an adult on premises in case
there's any kind of emergency and and
then you have a place that people think
it's safe and is safe and then you have
kids off their devices so I know a lot
of parents are worried about that
so you have three hours after school
when they're coming up with things to do
on their own and there was something
else great about it it's a safe place
there's there's a person there for an
emergency oh and there's enough kids
because so many times when I hear from
parents and what I think I'm hearing
from you is you want to have your kid
outside playing you know part of a pack
like when you were a kid but there's no
kids outside and that's because the kids
are in either a you know and don't let
activity somewhere or or they're home on
their devices so this is this is a third
place and it doesn't cost much you just
have to have some grown-up there and
then you're using the same facilities
that are there for the rest of the day
so it doesn't even make new insurance
problems for the school so it's it's
we've tried to come up with the simplest
possible things to do and these are them
those are the school initiatives that's
that's great and I want to show just a
last clip of the night is just a little
promo video of the free play that you
made on your site and so people can take
a look and get a sense of what goes on
there and then we'll come back and just
get you to tell people how they can make
this happen in their own community right
yes we'll be right back
it's not your imagination kids are
getting more anxious depressed
hypersensitive and you'd be too
you a micro managed as we tell them what
to do from the moment they wake up until
the moment they go to bed what's missing
old-fashioned free play you probably
played after-school best part of your
day but today kids are in organized
activities or on electronics or even if
they want to go out and play there's no
one outside to play with solution keep
schools open for free play before or
after school seven schools in a Long
Island New York school district started
to let grow play club the first rule of
play club is adults do not intervene in
play club initially when we decided we
were going to run this club and we were
going to have a hundred four more
children in one area playing and we
didn't want any adults intervention I
was a little nervous why not have adults
organize the activities because kids
figuring things out is the point of play
play is how children learn to direct
their own activity is how learn they
learn to create activities it's how they
learn to negotiate differences with
their playmates all of that is destroyed
when you've got an adult running it okay
so let's get an action item coming out
of this people who are inspired by that
or think that's really cool and want
that for their own children what's the
next step alright info at let grow org
is how you can write to us but go to let
grow org and you click on schools and
you will see that video about play club
electro play club there it is and and
the video and also instructions for the
let grow project all of our materials
are completely free talking to me on the
phone you can do it tomorrow actually
pretty busy you can do it later in the
week it's all free we respond to our
emails we're happy
two teachers principals superintendents
we really like the superintendents and
their these are not crazy difficult
initiatives especially the electro
project and we started something also if
you look on our site on my blog posts
like a couple of days ago John hight and
I did a let grow meetup for families who
wanted to meet each other because maybe
you can't get your school to do any of
these things immediately but you want to
find some local people who are willing
to send their kids out and you'll send
your kids out you have to sort of
renormalize it again so what we did is
we we announced it on meetup.com and on
Facebook and on Twitter you know anybody
who wants to come meet up and we we met
in Washington Square Park under the arch
and the children including John's
nine-year-old all went off to a
playground in one corner of the park
it's a big park and then the adults just
we got a lecture we got another cut so I
keep hearing John hi I was like my third
time that week of hearing a lecture from
John Hyde about what happened to
childhood and what was great is that the
kids had a fantastic time and they met
some of the other kids in the
neighborhood who now they can go to the
park together with because the parents
are used to being separate from the
children and the children have met
friends and they're used to being on
their own too so it's it's all about
renormalizing basically my childhood
we're just trying to make everybody's
childhood back to Lenore's childhood and
probably Zach's childhood where kids
played outside they had some spats they
had a lot of fun and they came home and
they had cookies and milk that sounds
good to me and I want to thank you for
this conversation Lenore I could
literally talk to you for another hour
and maybe it's the point of my life that
I'm in right now but it's all really
fascinating to me and I appreciate what
you're doing and I hope everyone who
enjoyed this conversation does go to
electrode org and thank you for tuning
in for the second installment of this I
was glancing at the chat every now and
then I see people are having fun in
their own conversations down there which
is great that's what this is all about
we're trying to create a little bit of a
forum here so
if you like what we're doing please let
us know if you don't like what we're
doing I guess you can let me know just
yell at me on Twitter or something and I
guess again we'll have we'll have I
thought you were anti all about being
anti so we will be back here tomorrow at
4 p.m. Eastern 1 p.m. Pacific talking to
Rick Doblin about something a little bit
different psychedelics and thank you for
tuning in and again if you want if you
have questions for Nick Gillespie about
post-modernism do hit us up at questions
at reason.com all right thank you we'll
see you tomorrow
[Music]